bonjour à toutes et à tous alors je suis
chargé d'être le premier speaker de
cette édition de thé liccioni incité
deux ou trois petits mots sur moi qui
suis-je
j'ai 22 ans je suis étudiant à
washington et pas en france et vous
allez en comprendre les raisons
mais avant tout il a raison qui me
pousse à parler ici dans pokémon des
jeunes d'implication une prise de
pouvoir c'est parce que à 18 ans après
les attentats de charlie hebdo j'ai
réalisé qu'on avait un énorme problème
en france
comment est ce qu'on allait faire pour
ne pas laisser les terroristes et les
extrémistes qu'ils soient religieux ou
politique
diviser notre société et comment est-ce
que nous la jeunesse on allait pouvoir
influer ça et faire en sorte de réparer
les blessures qui est ouverte
alors j'ai ouvert qui s'appelait réveil
citoyen pendant trois ans je les dirige
les ça a été un énorme plaisir dans ma
vie est une très grande étape pour moi
il y à un peu plus d'un an après avoir
quitté la direction de cette ong
je me suis posé la question qui est le
futur de la jeunesse ce sont les jeunes
dans les pays en développement
principalement et la démographie et la
croissance démographique l'expliquent
les chiffres sont clairs si l'on veut
construire un monde plus équitable plus
juste et plus en paix nous allons avoir
besoin de leur collaboration totale et
donc j'ai ouvert une nouvelle reine
celle qui s'appelle yang et 9 mbj et le
but c'est de donner à ces jeunes dans
les pays en développement
tous les outils dont ils ont besoin pour
développer leurs initiatives
mais voilà en france pour moi ç'a
toujours été très dur de mener de front
ses études et ses initiatives
de plus je travaille vraiment dur
alors il y a maintenant six ou sept mois
j'ai claqué la porte du système français
sans avoir un diplôme et je suis parti
étudier aux états unis pourquoi parce
qu'en france on a un problème de parts
ou l'éducation passe aujourd'hui
l'éducation en france c'est assieds toi
tais toi et écoute
il n'y a pas d'éducation de l'élève vers
les lèvres ou d'élèves vers le
professeur c'est uniquement le
professeur élève aucune opportunité
d'apprendre des uns et des autres
pourtant
jeunesse en france on a énormément à
apprendre d'elle elle est ultra
appliquée dans la lutte contre le
changement climatique
on a le réseau associatif parmi les plus
puissants du monde avec plus de 200
associations pour cendres pour dix mille
habitants
c'est tellement plus que l'allemagne qui
en a 70 tellement plus que les états
unis qui ont 57 mieux et ça c'est pour
la jeunesse + 34 % de participation des
15-35 ans en france entre 2015 et 2016
dans réseau associatif
autant vous dire que notre réservoir
d'énergie de la jeunesse est gigantesque
j'aimerais vous parler d'un exemple qui
je crois représente très bien les
problèmes que beaucoup de jaloux en
france les avocats nas à la fonder une
association qui s'appelle aïda qui lutte
contre le cancer de l'enfant un sujet
tellement important on avait 15 ans
quand elle s'est dit je vais faire
quelque chose elle est ok à toutes les
associations qui traite de ce problème
toutes sans exception duo répondu tu es
trop jeune fini ses études d'abord
revient le voir après et baala dit non
stop et à 15 ans à la clé son
association maintenant à la 18 ans
plusieurs centaines de bénévoles 80% aux
moins de 18 ans mais le problème c'est
que ce genre de personnage qui est
admirable et trop rare dans notre
société parce que trop souvent notre
système d'éducation nationale nous
apprend que notre ambition est bas il
faut la revoir à la baisse
alors comment faire comment faire pour
que ça change
comment faire pour que l'on puisse enfin
faire soulever les ambitions de la
genèse et les laisser s'exprimer
il faut diversifier l'apprentissage le
tronc commun
ça ne va pas le tronc commun aujourd'hui
c'est tout le monde et tu dis la même
chose au même niveau et en même temps
des matières qui parfois ne nous
importent très peu
alors oui il faut que nous ayons tous
des bases pour avoir un raisonnement
logique
oui il faut que tout le monde sache
compte et oui il faut que tout le monde
sache faire des analyses de l'écriture
qui ont du sens oui mais tout le monde
n'est pas obligé d'apprendre en même
temps à faire des fonctions à multiples
inconnues
donc il faut que l'on considère avant
tous deux nouvelles matières il faut que
l'on puisse introduire une dose de
spécialisation parce que la
professionnalisation dans la
scolarisation ce n'est pas un gros mot
nous devons pouvoir être capable de
proposer de la géopolitique des sciences
marines et toutes sortes de matières
auxquelles on ne pense pas et qui sont
beaucoup moins généraliste que celle que
nous avons aujourd'hui un système
scolaire et ensuite il faut que nous
puissions considérer l'extrascolaire
l'art la danse la musique
ce n'est pas parce qu'on fait de la
flûte à bec pendant un ou deux ans au
collège qu'on arrive à ouvrir notre
esprit à césar pire ceux qui le font en
dehors c'est considéré comme séparer du
scolaire hors l'extra scolaire et les
scolaires ça va ensemble ça ne peut pas
être séparé un élève très scolaire le
sera très probablement dans le scolaire
et beaucoup de pays dans l'organisme de
cette façon donc il faut que cet extra
scolaires puissent compter dans la
notation de l'élève
ensuite deuxième pilier learning by
doing
c'est quelque chose qui est très répandu
dans les pays anglophones
mais en france ça ne l'est pas et il
faut que l'on puisse le développer mais
nous avons un énorme obstacle à ça c'est
que nous stigmatisons les filières
professionnelles dans un conseil de
classe
quand tu entends les professeurs vers le
bilan de tes études et te dire bats toi
tu finiras en lycée pro a ou en bac pro
mais c'est quoi c'est une insulte alors
que beaucoup d'élèves des milliers des
millions d'élèves auraient pu bénéficier
d'un enseignement professionnel bien
avant s'ils auront elles avaient donné
l'heure les outils pour pouvoir
comprendre ce qu'ils avaient envie de
faire et donc on stigmatise ces filières
pro dont nous avons plus besoin que
jamais pire des matières disponible en
lycée pro qu'est ce qui empêche des
personnes qui sont fiers général d'y
aller et d'apprendre une mixité est
possible enfin moi j'aimerais parler
d'un exemple qui je pense est très
représentatif de ce manque de learning
by doing qui sont les stages de
troisième vous l'avez tous fait ici même
pas une blague
tellement ce n'est pas drôle vous êtes
là pendant une semaine ou à être un
poulet ou à observer de loin quelques
chanceux d'entre vous j'en suis sûr ont
eu de très bonnes expériences j'ai eu
une très bonne expérience mais on ne
nous apprend pas nous impliquer dans la
vie de l'entreprise ou de l'entité dans
laquelle nous sommes
nous sommes là en qualité d'observateurs
qu'est-ce que ça apprend à notre
jeunesse qu'on les bois rien que ce
qu'on a appris que ce soit l'expérience
de la vie dans l'extra scolaire ou dans
scolaire ne sert à rien j'ai pas dit que
vous deviez redresser les comptes de
l'entreprise
mais vous pouvez participer à la vie
d'autres entreprises dès le début d'une
scolarité au collège ou au lycée
et moi je pense aussi que vous devez
être rémunéré on vous parle pas de faire
une semaine entièrement rémunérés je
vous parle de faire plusieurs journées
pendant toute ma scolarité dans laquelle
vous êtes en entreprise et vous êtes
rémunéré pour le travail que vous faites
parce que tout comme les stages pour les
majeurs non payés c'est un scandale que
le travail ne soit pas rémunéré
troisième pilier c'est la flexibilité
d'éducation nous avons besoin de
développer des systèmes de classes à
niveaux graduée c'est à dire j'ai été
très mauvais en maths
pendant toute ma scolarité et par moi
j'aurais aimé ne pas être dans la même
classe de personnes qui étaient
excellentes pourquoi parce que je les
retarder et parce que ça ne leur
bénéficie en rien d'avoir quelqu'un qui
va entraîner la classe en dessous ce
dont j'avais besoin c'est d'être mis
dans une classe de mon niveau pour
pouvoir apprendre avec des gens de mon
niveau dans les pays anglo saxons dans
certains ils ont un système de algèbre
injecte 2 h 25
mais aussi d'anglais trois anglais un
svt histoire bref peu importe que vous
ne soyez pas dans la même classe de 4e
vous allez étudier des personnes qui ont
un âge différent du vôtre et toutes les
études à très très très grande majorité
des études qui ont été faites dans les
pays qui appliquent ce système montre
que la mixité sociale est bénéfique à
tout le monde et que cet échange entre
les différents âges au sein même d'un
rétablissement lors que parfois il ya un
ou deux ans de différence bénéficie sur
le long terme
encore une fois tout le monde et enfin
quatrième pilier il faut qu'on définisse
la vision de notre enseignement qu'est
ce qu'on veut pour la jeunesse de demain
le système français le logiciel
d'éducation français est périmé il est
obsolète et on n'a pas pensé à le
réformer
c'est très difficile de le faire mais on
n'y a pas pensé et la vision de
l'enseignement
je vais prendre encore un exemple qui me
sens en représentativité que on parle
beaucoup de jeunesse ouverte et mobiles
avec erasmus mais ouverte et mobiles à
quoi exactement
il faut qu'elle soit oubliée en france
pour qu'ils soient mobiles en europe ou
88 dans le monde
oui mais comment on fait ça par la
langue étrangère aujourd'hui 12 % des
collégiens en france ont un bon niveau
d'anglais
ces 84 % en suède
alors moi je veux bien entendre que le
système suédois a des défauts il en a
certainement je veux bien entendre que
le français est très important en france
parce que la francophonie est importante
et qu'il faut pérenniser le français
dans le temps et le mettre sur un
piédestal mais même tout ça n'excuse en
aucun cas 12% d'un bon niveau d'anglais
au collège rien solution immersion
totale
l'immersion totale ce sont des cours
n'ont pas de lv1 en lv1 s'assemble ça
semble assez logique mais des cours
ce qu'on a proposé deux variantes la
géopolitique les sciences marines dans
la langue de votre choix
bref vous l'avez compris énormément de
challenge devant nous c'est pas facile
mais tout ça ça va dans la catégorie du
parce que si on ne donne pas la jeunesse
des outils pour qu'elles croient en elle
même eh ben ça va être très dur d'avoir
une jeunesse qui représentera le futur
de la france soyouz empowerment essayer
de le traduire en français n'est pas
représentatif ça la seule chose que j'ai
trouvé en français qui représentent bien
ces deux mots c'est libérer le potentiel
de la jeunesse et ça représente pas le
vrai sens du terme
donc il faut qu'on prenne notre chance
parce qu'on ne la donnera pas mais les
adultes dans cette pièce donner leur
chance aux jeunes qui ont énormément à
prouver oui mais qui ont surtout
énormément à donner et nous devrons nous
les jeunes résister à une opposition qui
est structurelle c'est pas pour rien
qu'on appelle l'éducation nationale le
mammouth des politiques publiques
mais nous devons le faire et il va
falloir que l'on s'entraide
l'un de nos plus grands obstacles c'est
que quand un de nos amis nous parle d'un
projet ont fait mais attends tu vas pas
te concentrer sur tes études
attention ça demandait trop de temps
mais tu es sûr que tu peux faire ça
parce que t'as pas de compétence parce
que tu balances milieu avant tapaï
d'excellence professionnelle dedans
qu'est ce qui te fait penser que tu vas
y arriver on se met des bâtons dans nos
propres ou supporter on noue entre
jeunes et dont nous et créons une
jeunesse qui puisse prendre ce pouvoir
et je vais finir sur une phrase de
françoise sagan qui dit que la jeunesse
est bien c'est la génération la plus
raisonnable
alors au boulot voilà
[Applaudissements]